[Musique]
m
comme je descendais des fleuves
impassibles
je ne me sentis plus guidés par les à
leur dépôt rouge criard les avaient pris
pour cibles les ayants cloud est nu au
poteau de couleur gt1 soucieux de tous
les équipages porteurs de blé flamand ou
de coton anglais quand avec mais à
l'heure on finissait tapage
[Musique]
les flamands laisser descendre où je
voulais
[Musique]
en
à
où
dans le clapotement furieux démarrer moi
l'autre hiver plus sourd que les
cerveaux d'enfants je courus et les
péninsules démarrer n'ont pas subi tohu
bohu plus triomphant
[Musique]
la tempête a béni mais éveillent
maritime
[Musique]
plus léger qu'un bouchon
j'ai dansé sur les flots qu'on appelle
rouleur éternelle de victimes
[Musique]
et dès lors
je me suis baigné dans le poème de la
mer à fuser d'astres
et la t100
dévoré par les azur vert
[Musique]
ouf le thé sont blêmes et ravi un noyé
pensif parfois des sens
ou tu t'es niant tout à coup les bleus
irrités délirer rythme lent sous l'ére
utilement du jour plus forte que
l'alcool plus vaste que no lire fermente
les rousseur amer de l'amour
[Musique]
où
je sais les sucreries en éclair et
trombe et les ressacs et les courants je
sais le soir l'aube exalté ainsi qu'un
peuple de colombes et j'ai vu quelques
fois ce colom a cru voir j'ai vu le
soleil bas tâche et d'aurore mystique
illuminant delon figement en violet
pareils à des acteurs de drame très
antique les flots roulant au loin leurs
frissons de volée j'ai rêvé la nuit
verte aux neiges est ébloui baiser
montante aux yeux des mères avec lenteur
la circulation des saisines louis et
l'éveil jaune et bleu des phosphores
chanteur oui ce phosphore
étymologiquement lumière qui porte ce
phosphore blanc légèrement ambre et
lumineux dans l'obscurité
sophos fort qui a abandonné à la lumière
devient phosphore rouge c'est bien lui
qui m'a aidé à retrouver la clarté du
soleil le jour qui m'a permis d'espérer
retrouver ma mains de pianiste
ce spectre de la lumière blanche qui
cache les couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel
laisse est née de la lumière du soleil à
travers les innombrables minuscules
petites gouttes de pluie 17 qui arrange
olive la vie à partir du moment où on
les identifie c'est bien à califourchon
sur cet arc parfaitement et harmonieuse
m'encombrer aux couleurs franches que
j'ai rejoint cet espoir de lutter contre
ce pronostic médical post opératoires de
l'invalidité rouge ut dos à dos et à la
terre dans son énergie enraciné sûrement
dans son incandescence nos forêts vérité
brûlante
c'est la force de la danse la passion du
tango argentin
les tempes qui bat le coeur affoler la
courbure des corps dans l'arc en ciel de
la séduction du partage la sensualité de
la fusion de la beauté de l'amour
ces deux corps enlacés
ce sont eux qui m'ont aidé à franchir le
seuil du centre médical rocheland orange
c'est l'un des traits tout d'abord une
petite lumière jaune doré orange et qui
peu à peu s'intensifie qui glisse sur le
fjord entre les montagnes norvégiennes
ou père gunt et ingrid ont trouvé refuge
je vois là cet orange sanguine de grieg
ans pour prend tout le paysage gorgé de
lumière dans laquelle c'est orange nous
aimerions bien mordre tous jaune selmi
c'est le pays où les citronniers se
balance c'est le troll dodu de la vallée
de la clarée qui rassure par sa rondeur
c'est le colibri chanteur c'est le jaune
du ciel comme marc chagall nous offre
dans son tableau le songe d'une nuit
d'été
ses tableaux oniriques magique d'une
poésie intense que capte mon regard
après le tango pour rejoindre les soins
de rééducation il la peint en vert le
violoniste posée sur l'épaule de bottom
inspiration shakespearienne où la reine
des fées ensorcelé titiana est au bras
de ceux tisserand un sortilège a pourvu
d'une tête de bouc
mais elle versé la lumière que va nous
révéler le printemps dans ses nuances
naissante qui enjolivent le paysage mais
surtout l'inondent
c'est elle cette lumière la chanteuse
soprano color à tour de la planète de la
palette trop naissante le verre et la
lumière unissent leur sève leur sève
bouillonnante jaillissante pour redonner
vie aux arbres arbustes pour redonner
vie au grain enfouie dormantes en terre
aux alpages aux campagnes ondulé au parc
des villes et chaque brin d'herbe se
redresse tendus vers le ciel
tendu vers la lumière cette sève entre
donne encore dans nos esprits qui
reprennent vie à contre courant des
difficultés quotidiennes de la
souffrance des pronostics médicaux ou
négatifs bleus c'est la note sal dans
son art poétique paul verlaine nous
invite au rêve avec le bleu fouillis des
clercs étoiles pour arthur rimbaud le
bleu c'est la voyelle aux suprêmes
clairon plein dé ce thriller étrange
monde traversé des anges all oméga rayon
violet de ses yeux bleu le ciel dans son
architecture dans son ampleur dans son
immensité tout bleu pur bleu la mer qui
ouvre l'horizon le bleu invite à la
vérité à la sérénité à la confiance en
soi retrouver à la persévérance à la
volonté de boue et en mouvement nous
nous voilà de bruit en mouvement c'est
notre grand poète chanteur éternelle qui
seraient contents le/la diapason c'est
l'indigo c'est la couleur des peuples
nomades de l'afrique celle vertigineuse
et vibrante du souffle du silence qui
autorise la survie au rythme lento
espressivo du pas des chameaux
ces lettres accompli la lumière
intérieure qui éclaire les visages aller
rider buriné avec ses yeux
impressionnant à fuser de bonté et de
sagesse à contre-courant de la nature
hostile les lutine odorantes embusqués
dans les sous bois en sont habillés lors
vue et leur parfum régaler frédéric le
poète chanteur du piano romantique
ce poète subtil et délicat et il adorait
les retrouver à son retour de noah sur
le rebord de sa cheminée dans son salon
de musique parisien c'est le viol est
bien sûr la spiritualité et rudolf
steiner nous dit que l'homme qui vit
dans la musique vit dans une image
reflet de son berceau spirituel la
musique et l'art de l'abstraction elle
s'élève au dessus des mots c'est quelque
chose de l'essence même au delà de
l'insurmontable it et du langage elle
n'est pas un accessoire de plaisir pour
la vie elle est le signe de la
perfection de la vie elle exprime la vie
en soi dans sa pulpe la plus intime nist
pardon nietzsche nous dit sans la
musique la vie serait une erreur et
quand ils écoutent beethoven il entend
de la musique sur la musique et il
estime que les mélodies sont des
réminiscences transfiguré d'un monde
meilleur
un peu comme les idées de platon pour
lui la musique allège le corps nous
libère de la pesanteur nous libère de la
vie de plomb et nous invite accueillir
ces moments présents dans toute
situation et que l'on a parfois du mal à
reconnaître
à la fin de sa vie nietzsche réécrit sa
citation
et il nous dit que la vie sans musique
serait tout simplement non seulement une
erreur mais une torture un exil le reste
est silence avec la musique nous ne
manquons ni d'enfance ni de tentes
rising d'émerveillement et la poésie et
la musique que tout homme porte en soi
affirme shakespeare et cette écriture
c'est sûrement cette peinture de la voie
que j'identifie voltaire et cette
écriture et faites des mots qui sont les
passants mystérieux de l'âme dont nous
parle victor hugo grâce à la poésie qui
a assuré l'intérim lorsque je ne pouvais
plus jouer du piano lorsque mon bras
droit
mama mes doigts étaient comme amputé
j'ai pu renouer avec la vie allait à
contre-courant
là aussi jouer du piano
c'est une aventure intemporel le verbe
jouer serait fertile à quelques
amusement comme si on allait sauter
s'outiller picorer les notes d'un
registre à l'autre n'ont joué du piano
c'est l'apprivoiser c'est le séduire le
taquiner le bousculer l'habiter le
caresser le pénétrer les mais il faut
faire qu'un avec lui jouer du piano
c'est entrer dans l'os ont vibré dans la
résonance
c'est être hors du temps suspendu délice
enchantement émerveillement bonheur
félicité oui j'ai transformé la
souffrance
cette souffrance qui m'habitait je lai
apprivoiser et une fois qu'elle a été en
moi je lai pétri jeu les modeler jusqu'à
ce qu'elle devienne joie joie de vivre
métaux vannes disait que la souffrance
pouvait se transformer en joie oui j'ai
marché longtemps courageusement depuis
que cet interne inexpérimenté à piquer
mes nerfs depuis le 4 novembre 2011
ce sont les sourires les rires les
éclats de rire
la gym 8 et la fraîcheur de mes petits
enfants c'est leur source
là la ressource que j'ai trouvé dans
cette vallée de la clarée pur vibrante
c'est un trou de verdure où chante une
rivière accrochant follement aux herbes
des haillons d'âge d'argent ou le soleil
de la montagne fyr lui c'est un petit
val qui mousse de rayon cette vallée
vibrante de nature c'est au cool sur les
petits cailloux se murmure je les ai
écoutés je les ai admiré
j'ai eu mais c'est air vivifiant et pure
et j'ai bu à l'eau des sources
j'ai caressé la pelouse alpine fleury je
suis rentré dans ce paysage je me suis
fondu jusqu'à que je puisse renouer avec
la vie
paul diel disait que l'être humain est
fluide rééducable jusqu'à la mort et
qu'il a en lui les ressources
inconnu des ressources inconnu jusqu'à
ce qu'il ait vraiment besoin de s'en
servir que cela devienne impératif vital
alors je les ai employer ses ressources
le passé et vivant dans la lumière
mais la joie au coeur sourire en
bandoulière
vous allez sûrement atteindre votre
fusil votre kilimandjaro votre everest
et lorsque vous serez dans le ciel dans
ce bleu du ciel pur vous allez vous
sentir bien dans cette infinie que l'on
croit bleus et vous allez vous sentir
léger puis ont de plus en plus pure de
plus en plus sage de plus en plus vivant
vous allez planer flotter peut-être même
allez vous rencontrer antoine de
saint-exupéry dans son lightning 38 avec
à son bord le petit prince sa rose et le
renard alors vous aurez transformer
votre souffrance vous ne serez plus dans
le courant vous aurait tourné dos au
courant ou se répartit avec son flot son
flow vif et tumultueux et cette force
qui vous transmet vous redonnera vie
ce contre-courant je lui ai donc tourné
le dos me voici dans le courant ce
courant dovi transmissibles je suis une
passeuse
[Applaudissements]